study  [Music]  excuse me sir  do you know where i might find a bus to  sailor  front of grocery on the hour  do you know when that might be  your religious group not teach you to  read  look at the schedule  so  [Music]  i'll take this to the back for late to  review tomorrow i appreciate you thanks  hey  are you all right  have you seen this girl  hi sir how can i help you just looking  something for your kids  hi  sorry uh  who if i join  you're from the disciples of dawn right  you are  running from the colony like  like leaving them  we don't see all much  here  oh  i'm tasha  thank you for helping me  uh it's yours  a gift between new friends although  friends usually know one another's names  carrie  my name is carrie  your name  carrie  i think you might need a disguise  you